[Música]
en un día largo vagando por el bosque
para encontrar granos y hierbas el
granjero sheng nong agotado y divino se
envenenó 72 veces por accidente pero
antes de que el veneno terminara con su
vida una hoja cayó en su boca la masticó
y revivió y es así como descubrimos el
té o por lo menos eso dice una leyenda
el té actualmente no cura venenos pero
la historia de el mítico inventor chino
de la agricultura destaca la importancia
del té en la china antigua la evidencia
arqueológica sugiere que el té se
cultivaba allí hace seis mil años o 1500
años antes de que los faraones
construyeran las pirámides esa planta de
té original china es el mismo tipo que
se cultiva en todo el mundo hoy en día
pero se consumía de forma muy diferente
se comió como verdura o cocinada con
avena
el té solo cambia de ser comido a ser
bebido hace 1500 años cuando la gente
vio que la combinación del calor y la
humedad podía generar un sabor complejo
y variado con esas hojas
tras cientos de años con variaciones del
método de preparación el estándar se
convirtió en calentar el té empaquetarlo
en bloques portables molerlo en polvo
mezclarlo con agua caliente y crear una
bebida llamada mocha o macha el matcha
se volvió tan popular que surgió una
cultura del té en China el té fue el
tema de libros y poesía la bebida
favorita de emperadores y un medio para
artistas dibujaban imágenes
extravagantes en la espuma del té muy
parecido al arte del expreso que se ve
actualmente en el siglo 9 durante la
dinastía Tank un monje japonés llevó la
primera planta de tea Japón Los
japoneses desarrollaron sus propios
rituales únicos con el té y crearon la
ceremonia japonesa del té y en el siglo
xiv durante la dinastía el emperador
chino cambió la norma del té en bloques
al té de hojas suelta entonces china
Todavía tenía el monopolio de los
árboles del té del mundo y hacía del té
una de las tres exportaciones esenciales
de China junto con la porcelana y la
seda esto le dio un gran poder e
influencia económica a China cuando
beber té se difundió por el mundo hacia
principios de 1600 cuando comerciantes
holandeses llevaron té a Europa en
grandes cantidades muchos atribuyen a la
reina Catherine de braganza noble
portuguesa el hacer popular el té entre
la aristocracia inglesa al casarse con
el Rey Carlos II en 1661 Gran Bretaña
estaba expandiendo su influencia
colonial y se convertía en el nuevo
poder dominante del mundo y al crecer
Gran Bretaña el interés por el test se
difundió en todo el mundo hacia 1700 el
tn Europa se vendía 10 veces más caro
que el café y la planta todavía se
cultivaba solo en China el comercio del
té era tan lucrativo que el cli la nave
más rápida del mundo se creó debido a la
competencia entre comerciantes todos
competían por llevar el té a Europa
rápido para maximizar sus ganancias
primero Gran Bretaña pagó por el té
chino con plata al resultar demasiado
caro propusieron intercambiar el té con
otras substancia el opio eso provocó un
problema de salud pública en China
porque la gente se volvió adicta a la
droga en 1839 un funcionario chino
ordenó a sus hombres destruir
cargamentos de opio de Gran Bretaña como
declaración contra la influencia de Gran
Bretaña esto provocó la Primera Guerra
del opio entre las dos naciones la lucha
continuó por toda la costa hasta 1842
cuando la dinastía shink derrotada se
dio el puerto de Hong Kong a los
británicos y retomó el comercio la
guerra debilitó la posición global de la
china durante más de un siglo
la compañía británica de las indias
orientales quiso cultivar té sola y así
controlar más el mercado entonces
encargaron Al botánico robertchen
robarte en China en una operación
encubierta se disfrazó y emprendió un
viaje peligroso por las regiones chinas
de té contrabandeo árboles y
trabajadores especializados hacia
Darling India donde la planta se
difundió aún más y contribuyó a aumentar
su expansión como producto cotidiano hoy
el té es la bebida más consumida en el
mundo después del agua Y desde el té
dulce Turco de risa alteza lado del
Tíbet existen casi tantas maneras de
preparar la bebida como culturas en el
mundo
[Música]
otra bebida con una larga historia es el
alcohol rastree sus orígenes en la
antigua China y descubra Cómo
evolucionaron las bebidas fermentadas a
lo largo de miles de años con este video
[Música]